The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
I hope you didn't spend
time doing 6002 problem
sets while eating turkey.
It's not recommended
for digestion.
But I hope you're ready to go
back into diving into material.
And since it's been a week
since we got together,
let me remind you of
what we were doing.
We were looking at the
issue of how to understand
experimental data.
Data could come from
a physical experiment.
We had the example of
measuring the spring
constant of a linear spring.
Could come from biological data.
Could come from social data.
And what we looked
out was the idea
of how do we actually
fit models to that data
in order to understand them.
So what I want to do is I want
to start with that high level
reminder of what we were after.
I want to do about
a five minute recap
of what we were doing last time,
because it has been a while.
And then we're
going to talk about
how do you actually
validate models
that you're fitting to data to
understand are they really good
fits or not.
And if you remember.
I know you spend all your
time thinking about 6002.
You should remember I
left you with a puzzle,
where I fit data to--
sorry, fit models
to some noisy data.
And there was a question
of, did the model
really have an order 16 fit?
Right, so what are
we trying to do?
Remember, our goal is to try
and model experimental data.
And really what we want to do is
have a model that both explains
the phenomena
underlying what we see,
gives us a sense of what
might be the underlying
physical mechanism, the
underlying social mechanism,
and can let us make
predictions about the behavior
in new settings.
In the case of my spring,
being able to predict
what will the displacement
be when I actually
put a different weight on it
than something I measured.
Or if you want to think
from a design perspective,
working the other
direction and saying,
I don't want my spring to
deflect more than this amount
under certain kinds of weights.
So how do I use the
model to tell me
what the spring constant
should be for the spring I
want in that case?
So we want to be able to predict
behavior in new settings.
The last piece we know is
that, if the data was perfect,
this is easy.
But it ain't.
There's always
going to be noise.
There's always going to be
experimental uncertainty.
And so I really want to
account for that uncertainty
when I fit that model.
And while sometimes I'll have
theories that will help--
Hooke says models of
springs are linear--
in some cases, I don't.
And in those cases, I want to
actually try and figure out
what's the best model
to fit even when I don't
know what the theory tells me.
OK, so quick recap, what
do we use to solve this?
So we've got a set
of observed values.
My spring case for different
displays for different masses
I measured the displacements.
Those displacements
are my observed values.
And if I had a model
that would predict
what the displacement
should be, I
can measure how good the fit is
by looking at that expression
right there, the
sum of the squares
of the differences between
the observed and the
predicted data.
As I said, we could
use other measures.
We could use a first
order and absolute value.
The square is actually
really handy, because it
makes the solution space
very easy to deal with,
which we'll get to in a second.
So given observed
data, get a prediction.
I can use the sum of
squared differences
to measure how good the fit is.
And then the second
piece is I now
what to find what's the best
way to predict the data.
What's the best curve
that fits the data.
What's the best model for
protecting the values.
And we suggest that
last time, we'll
focus on mathematical
expressions, polynomials.
Professor Guttag is so excited
about polynomial expressions,
he's throwing
laptops on the floor.
Please don't do
that to your laptop.
We're going to fit polynomials
to these expressions.
And since the polynomials
have some coefficients,
the game is basically,
how do I find
the coefficients of
the polynomial that
minimize that expression.
And that, we said, was an
example of linear regression.
So let me just remind you
what linear regression says.
Simple example,
case of the spring.
I'm going to get a
degree 1 polynomial.
So that is something of
the form y is ax plus b.
a and b are the three variables,
the parameters I can change.
And the idea is for every
x, in the case of my spring,
for every mass, I'm
going to use that model
to predict what's
the displacement,
measure the
differences, and find
the thing that minimizes it.
So I just want to
find values of a and b
that let me predict values
that minimize that expression.
As I suggested, you
could solve this.
You could write code to do it.
It's a neat little
piece of code to write.
But fortunately, PiLab
provides that for you.
And I just want to give
you the visualization
of what we're doing here.
And then we're going
to look at examples.
I'm going to try to
find the best line.
It's represented by
two values, a and b.
I could represent
all possible lines
in a space that has
one access with values
and the other access
with b values.
Every point in that plane
defines a line for me.
Now imagine a surface laid over
this two dimensional space,
where the value or the
height of the surface
is the value of that objective
function at every point.
Don't worry about
computing it all,
but just imagine
I could do that.
And by the way, one
of the nice things
about doing sum of squares
is that surface always
has a concave shape.
And now the idea of
linear regression
is I'm going to start at
some point on that surface.
And I'm just going
to walk downhill
until I get to the bottom.
There will always be
one bottom, one point.
And once I get to that
point, that a and b value
tell me the best line.
So it's called linear
regression because I'm linearly
walking downhill on this space.
Now I'm doing this for line
with two parameters a,b,
because it's easy to visualize.
If you're a good mathematician
even if you're not,
you can generalize this to think
about arbitrary dimensions.
So a fourth order surface
in a five dimensional space,
for example, would solve
a cubic example of this.
That's the idea of
linear regression.
That's what we're going to
use to actually figure out,
to find the best solution.
So here was the example I used.
I gave you a set of data.
In about 3 slides,
I'm going to tell you
where the data came from.
But I give you a set of data.
We could fit the best
line to this using
that linear regression idea.
And again, last piece
of reminder, I'm
going to use polyfit from PiLab.
It just solves that
linear regression problem.
And I give it a set of x values.
I give a corresponding
set of y values,
need to be the same
number in each case.
And I give it a dimension.
And in this case, one says,
find the best fitting line.
It will produce
that and return it
as a tuple, which I'll store
under the name model 1.
And I could plot it out.
So just remind you, polyfit
will find the best fitting n
dimensional surface, n being
that last parameter there,
and return it.
In a second, we're going to
use polyval, which will say,
given that model and
a set of x values,
predict what the
y value should be.
Apply them.
OK, so I fit the line.
What do you think?
Good fit?
Not so much, right?
Pretty ugly.
I mean, you can
see it's probably
the best-- or not probably.
It is the best fitting line.
It sort of accounts for the
variation on either side of it.
But it's not a very good fit.
So then the question
is, well why not
try fitting a
higher order model?
So I could fit a quadratic.
That is a second order model.
y equals ax squared
plus bx plus c.
Run the same code.
Block that out.
And I get that.
That's the linear model.
There's the quadratic model.
At least my [? i ?] our
looks a lot better, right?
It looks like it's following
that data reasonably well.
OK, I can fit a linear model.
I can fit a quadratic model.
What about higher order models?
What about a fourth order
model, an eighth order
model, a 644th order model?
How do I know which one
is going to be best?
So for that, I'm going to remind
you of the last thing we used.
And then we're going to start
talking about how to use it
further, which is if we
try fitting higher order
polynomials, do we
get a better fit?
And to do that, we
need to measure what
it means for the data to fit.
If I don't have any
other information.
For example, if I don't
have a theory that tells me
this should be linear
in the case afoot,
then the best way to do it
is to use what's called,
the coefficient of
determination, r-squared.
It's a scale independent
thing, which is good.
By scale independent, I
mean if I take all the data
and stretch it out,
this will still
give me back the same
value in terms of the fit.
So it doesn't depend on
the size of the data.
And what it does is it
basically tells me the
a value between
0 and 1, how well
does this model fit the data.
So just to remind
you, in this case,
the y's are the
measured values, the p's
are the predicted values.
That's what my model is saying,
for each one of these cases.
And mu down here is
the mean or the average
of the measured values.
The way to think about this
is this top expression here.
Well, that's exactly what I'm
trying to minimize, right?
So it's giving me an
estimate or a measure
of the error in the estimates
between what the model says
and what I actually measure.
And the denominator down
here basically tells
me how much does the data
vary away from the mean value.
Now here's the idea.
If in fact, I can
get this to 0, I
can get a model that completely
accounts for all the variation
in the estimates, that's great.
It says, the model
has fit perfectly.
And that means this is 0 so
this r value or r squared value
is 1.
On the other hand, if this
is equal to that, meaning
that all of the variation
in the estimates
accounts for none of the
variation in the data,
then this is 1 and
this goes to 0.
So the idea is that an r-squared
value is close to 1 is great.
It says, the model is
a good fit to the data.
r-squared value is getting
closer to 0, not so good.
OK, so I ran this,
fitting models of order 2,
4, 8, and 16.
Now you can see that model 2,
that's the green line here.
That's the one
that we saw before.
It's basically a
parabolic kind of arc.
It kind of follows
the data pretty well.
But if I look at those
r-squared values.
Wow, look at that.
Order 16 fit accounts
for all but 3%
of the variation in the data.
It's a great fit.
And you can see.
You can see how it follows.
It actually goes through
most, but not quite all,
of the data points.
So it's following
them pretty well.
OK, so if that's the
case, the order 16 fit
is really the best fit.
Should we just use it?
And I left you last time
with that quote that says,
from your parents, right,
your mother telling you,
just because you
can do something
doesn't mean you
should do something.
I'll leave it at that.
Same thing applies here.
Why are we building the model?
Remember, I said two reasons.
One is to be able to
explain the phenomena.
And the second one is to be
able to make predictions.
So I want to be able to
explain the phenomena
in the case of a spring,
with things like it's linear
and then that gives me a
sense of a linear relationship
between compression and force.
In this case, a
16th order model,
what kind of physical process
has an order 16 variation?
Sounds a little painful.
So maybe not a great
insight into the process.
But the second reason is I
want to be able to predict
future behavior of this system.
In the case of this spring,
I put a different weight
on than I've done before.
I want to predict what the
displacement is going to be.
I've done a set of trials for
an FDA approval of a drug.
Now I want to predict
the effect of a treatment
on a new patient.
How do I use the model
to help me with that?
One that maybe not
so good, currently, I
want to predict the
outcome of an election.
Maybe those models need to
be fixed from, at least, what
happened the last time around.
But I need to be able
to make the prediction.
So another way of saying it
is, a good model both explains
the phenomena and let's
me make the predictions.
OK, so let's go back,
then, to our example.
And before I do it, let me tell
you where that data came from.
I actually built that data
by looking at another kind
of physical phenomenon.
And it was a lot of them.
Things that follow
a parabolic arc.
So for example, comets.
Any particle under the influence
of a uniform gravitational
field follows a
parabolic arc, which
i why Halley's comet gets
really close for a while,
and then goes away off
into the solar system,
and comes back around.
My favorite example--
I'm biased on this.
And I know you all know
which team I root for.
But there is Tom Brady throwing
a pass against the Pittsburgh
Steelers.
Center of mass of the past
follows a nice parabolic arc.
Even in design, you
see parabolic arcs
in lots of places.
They have nice
properties in terms
of disbursement of
loads and forces,
which is why architects
like to use them.
So here's how I
generated the data.
I wrote a little function.
Actually, I didn't.
Professor Guttag did,
but I borrowed it.
It took in three
parameters, a, b, and c.
ax squared plus bx plus c.
I gave it a set of x values.
Those are the independent
measurements, the things
along the horizontal axis.
And notice what I did.
I generated values given an a,
b, and c, for that equation.
And then I added in some noise.
So random.guass takes a mean
and a standard deviation,
and it generates noise
following that bell shaped curve
that goes in the distribution.
So the 0 says it's 0 mean,
meaning there's no bias.
It's going to be equally likely
to be above or below the value,
positive or negative.
But 35 is a pretty good
standard deviation.
This is putting a lot
of noise into the data.
And then I just added
that into y values.
The rest of this,
you can see, it's
simply going to write it into a
file, a set of x and y values.
But this will generate, given
a value for a, b, and c,
data from a parabolic arc
with noise added to it.
And in this case, I took
it as y equals 3x squared.
And then c and c are 0.
And that's how I generated it.
What I want to do, I want to
see how well this model actually
predicts behavior.
So one of the ways
I could do it,
to say, all right, the question
I want to ask is, whoa,
if I generated the data
from a degree 2 polynomial
quadratic, why in the world is
the 16th order polynomial the,
"best fit?"
So let's test it out.
I'm going to give 3-- sorry, 4.
I can't count.
4 different degrees, order 2,
order 4, order 8, order 16.
And I've generated two
different datasets,
using exactly that code.
I just ran it twice.
It's going to have
slightly different values,
because the noise is going
to be different in each case.
But they're both
coming from that a,
y equals 3x squared equation.
And the code here
basically says,
I'm going to take
those two data sets
and basically, get the x
and y values out, and then
fit models.
So I'll remind
you, genFits takes
in a collection of x
and y values and a list
or a tuple of degrees,
and for each degree,
finds, using Polyfit,
the best model.
So models one will be 4 models
for order 2, 4, 8, and 16.
And similarly, down here, I'm
going to do the same thing,
but using the second data set.
And I'm going to fit,
again, a set of models.
And then I'll remind you, test
fits, which you saw last time.
I know it's a while
ago, basically takes
a set of models, a corresponding
set of degrees, x and y values,
and says, for each model
in that degree, measure
how well that model
meets the fit, using
that r-squared value.
So testFits is going to get us
back a set of r-squared values.
All right, with that in
mind, I've got the code here.
Let's run it.
And here we go.
I'm going to run that code.
Ha, I get two fits.
Looks good.
Let's look at the values.
So there's the first data set.
All right, the green line
still is doing not a bad job.
The purple line, boy, is
fitting it really well.
And again, notice
here's the best fit.
That's amazing.
That is accounting
for all but 0.4%
of the variation in the data.
Great fit.
Order 16.
Came from an order 2 thing.
All right, what about
the second data set?
Oh, grumph.
It also says order 16
fit is the best fit.
Not quite as good.
It accounts for all but
about 2% of the variation.
Again, the green line,
the red line, do OK.
But in this case,
again, that purple line
is still the best fit.
So I've still got this puzzle.
But I didn't quite test
what I wanted, right?
I said I want to see how well
it predicts new behavior.
Here what I did was I took
two datasets, fit the model,
and I got two different
fits, one for each dataset.
They both fit well for order 16.
But they're not quite right.
OK, so best fitting
model is still order 16
but we know it came from
an order 2 polynomial.
So how could I will
get a handle on seeing
how good this model is?
Well, what we're seeing here
is coming from training error.
Or another way of saying
it is, what we're measuring
is how well does
the model perform
on the data from
which it was learned?
How well do I fit the
model to the training data?
I want a small training error.
And if you think about it,
go back to the first example,
when I fit a line to this
data, it did not do well.
It was not a good model.
When I fit a quadratic,
it was pretty decent.
And then I got better
and better as I went on.
So I certainly need at least
a small training error.
But it's, to use the
mathematical terms,
a necessary, but not sufficient
condition to get a great model.
I need a small training
error, but I really
want to make sure that the model
is capturing what I'd like.
And so for that, I want
to see how well does
it do on other gen
data, generated
from the same
process, whether it's
weights on springs, different
comets besides Haley's comet,
different voters
than those surveyed
when we tried to
figure out what's
going to happen in an election.
And I'm set up to
do that, by using
a really important tool called,
validation or cross-validation.
We set the stage, and then
we're going to do the example.
I'm going to get a set of data.
I want to fit a model
to it, actually,
different models,
different degrees,
different kinds of models.
To see how well
they work, I want
to see how well they predict
behavior under other data
than that from which
I did the training.
So I could do that right here.
I could generate the
models from one data set,
but test them on the other.
And so in fact, I
had one data set.
I build a set of models
for the first data set.
I compared how well it
did on that data set.
But I could now apply it
to the second dataset.
How well does that
account for that data set?
And similarly, take the models
I built for the second data set,
and see how well they
predict the points
from the first dataset.
What do I expect?
Certainly, expect
that the testing error
is likely to be larger
than the training error,
because I train on
one set of data.
And that means this
ought to be a better way
to think about, how well
does this model generalize?
How well does it
predict other behavior,
besides what I started with.
So here's the code
I'm going to use.
It's pretty straightforward.
All I want to draw your
attention to here is, remember,
models one I built by fitting
models of degree 2, 4, 8,
and 16 to the first data set.
And I'm going to apply those
models to the second dataset,
x vals 2 and y vals 2.
Similarly, I'm going to
take the models built
for the second data set, and
test them on the first dataset
to see how well they fit.
I know you're
eagerly anticipating,
as I've been setting
this up for a whole week.
All right, let's look at
what happens when I do this.
I'm going to run it.
And then we'll look
at the examples.
If I go back over to
Python and this code
was distributed earlier, if you
want to play with it yourself.
Should be the right
place to do it.
I am going to run that code.
Now I get something
a little different.
In fact, if I go
look at it, here
is model one applied
to data set 2.
And we can both eyeball it
and look at the numbers.
Eyeballing it, there's that
green line, still generally
following the form
of this pretty well.
What about the purple line?
The order 16 degree.
Remember, that's the
purple line from model 1,
from training set 1.
Wow, this misses a bunch
of points, pretty badly.
And in fact, look at
the r-squared values.
Order 2 and order
4, pretty good fit,
accounts for all but
about 14, 13% of the data.
Look what happened to the
degree 16, degrees 16 fit.
Way down at last.
0.7.
Last time around it was 0.997.
What about the other direction?
Taking the model built
and the second data
set, testing it on
the first data set.
Again, notice a nice
fit for degree 2 and 4,
not so good for degree 16.
And just to give you a sense
of this, I'm going to go back.
There is the model one case.
There is the model
in the other case.
You can see the model that
accounts for variation in one
doesn't account for the
variation in the other, when
I look at order 16 fit.
OK, so what this says
is something important.
Now I can see.
In fact, if I look back
at this, if I were just
looking at the coefficient
of determination,
this says, in order to
predict other behavior,
I'm better off with an order
2 or maybe order 4 polynomial.
Those r-squared values
are both the same.
I happen to know it's
order 2, because that's
where I generated from.
But that's a whole lot
better than order 16.
And what you're seeing here is
an example of something that
happens a lot in statistics.
And in fact, I would suggest is
often misused in fitting data
to statistical samples.
It's called overfitting.
And what it means
is I've let there
be too many degrees of
freedom in my model, too
many free parameters.
And what it's fitting isn't
just the underlying process.
It's also fitting to the noise.
The message I want you to take
out of this part of the lecture
is, if we only fit the
model to training data,
and we look at how
well it does, we
could get what looks
like a great fit,
but we may actually have come
up with far too complex a model.
Order 16 instead of order 2.
And the only way you
are likely to detect
that is to train on one test
set and test on a different.
And if you do that, it's likely
to expose whether, in fact, I
have done a good job
of fitting or whether I
have overfit to the data.
There are lots of horror
stories in the literature,
especially from early days
of machine learning of people
overfitting to data and
coming up with models
that they thought wonderfully
predicted an effect,
and then when it ran on new
data really hit the big one.
All right, so this
is something you
want to try and stay away from.
And the best way to do
it is to do validation.
You can see it here, right?
The upper left is my
training data, dataset one.
There's the set of models.
This is now taking
that and applying it
to a different dataset
from the same process.
And notice for the
degree to polynomial,
the coefficient of
determination, 0.86, now 0.87.
The fact that it's slightly
higher is just accidental.
But it's really
about the same level.
It's doing the same kind of
drop on the training data
and on the test data.
On the other hand, degree 16,
coefficient of determination
is a wonderful 0.96 here and
a pretty awful 9 down there.
And that's a sign that
we're not in good shape,
when in fact our
coefficient of determination
drops significantly when
we try and handle new data.
OK, so why do we
get a better fit
on the training data with
a higher order model,
but then do less well when we're
actually handling new data?
Or another way of saying it
is, if I started out with,
in the case of that with
that data, a linear model
it didn't fit well, and then
I got to a quadratic model,
why didn't that quadratic
model still say [INAUDIBLE]?
Why was it the case that, as I
added more degrees of freedom,
I did better.
Or another way of asking it
is, can I actually get a worse
fit to training data as I
increase the model complexity?
And I see at least one
negative head shake.
Thank you.
You're right.
I cannot.
Let's look at why.
If I add in some
higher order terms,
and they actually don't matter.
If I got perfect data, the
coefficient will just be 0.
The fit will basically say,
this term doesn't matter.
Ignore it.
And that'll work
in perfect data.
But if the data is noisy,
what the model is going to do
is actually start
fitting the noise.
And while it may lead to
a better r-squared value,
it's not really a better fit.
Right, let me show you
an example of that.
I'm going to fit a quadratic
to a straight line.
Easy thing to do.
But I want to show you the
effect of overfitting or adding
in those extra terms.
So let me say it a
little bit better.
I'm going to start off
with this 3, sorry, 3.
I'm doing it again today.
4 simple values, 0, 1, 2, 3.
The y values are the
same as x values.
So this is 0,0, 1, 1, 2, 2, 3 3.
They're all lying on a line.
But I'm going to fit.
I'm going to plot them out.
And then I'm going
to fit a quadratic.
y if it equals ax squared
plus bx plus c to this.
Now I know it's a
line, but I want
to see what happens
if I fit a quadratic.
So I'm going to use polyfit
to fit my quadratic.
I'm going to print out
some data about it.
And then I'm going to
use Polyval to estimate
what those values should be.
Plot them out.
And then compute r squared
value, and see what happens.
All right, OK, and let
me set this up better.
What am I doing?
I want to just fit it to a line.
I know it's a line, but I'm
going to fit a quadratic to it.
And what I'd expect is, even
though there's an extra term
there, it shouldn't matter.
So if I go to Python,
and I run this,
I run exactly that
example, look at that.
a equals 0, b is 1, c equals 0.
Look at the r-squared value.
I'll pull that together for you.
It says, in this perfect
case, there's what I get.
The blue line is drawn
through the actual values.
The dotted red line is drawn
through the predicted values.
They exactly line up.
And in fact, the
solution implied
says, the higher order
term coefficient 0,
it doesn't matter.
So what it found was y equals x.
I know you're totally impressed
I could find a straight line.
But notice what happened there.
I dropped or that
system said, you
don't need the
higher order term.
Wonderful r-squared value.
OK, let's see how
well it predicts.
Let's add in one more
point, out at 20.
So this is 0, 1, 2, 3.
That's 0, 1, 2, 3.
I'm going to add 20 in there, so
it's 0, 0 , 1, 2, 2, 3, 3, 20,
20.
Again, I can estimate
using the same model.
So I'm not
recomputing the model,
the model I predicted from using
those first set of four points.
I can get the
estimated y values,
plot those out, and you again,
compute the r-squared value
here.
And even adding that point
in, there's the line.
And guess what.
Perfectly predicts it.
No big surprise.
So it says, in the
case of perfect data,
adding the higher order terms
isn't going to cause a problem.
The system will say
coefficients are 0.
That's all I need.
All right, now, let's go back
and add in just a tiny bit
of noise right there.
0, 0, 1, 1, 2, 2, and 3, 3.1.
So I've got a slight deviation
in the y value there.
Again, I can plot them.
I'm going to fit a
quadratic to them.
I'm going to print out
some information about it
and then get the
estimated values using
that new model to see
what it should look like.
I'm not going to run it.
I'm going to show
you the result.
I get a really good
r-squared value.
And there's the equation
it comes up with.
Not so bad, right?
It's almost y equal to x.
But because of that
little bit of noise
there, there's a small
second order term
here and a little
constant term down there.
The y squared value
is really pretty good.
And if you really squint
and look carefully at this,
you'll actually see
there's a little bit
of a deviation between
the red and the blue line.
It undershoots-- sorry,
overshoots there,
undershoots here, but
it's really pretty close.
All right, so am I just
whistling in the dark here?
What's the difference?
Well, now let's add
in that extra point.
And what happens?
So again, I'm now taking the
same set of points 0, 0, 1, 1,
2, 2, 3, and 3.1.
I'm going to do 20, 20.
Using the model I captured
from fitting to that first set,
I want to see what happens here.
Crap.
I'm sorry.
Shouldn't say that.
Darn.
Pick up some other word.
Shouldn't surprise you, right?
A small variation here is
now causing a really large
variation up there.
And this is why the ideal case
overfitting is not a problem,
because the coefficients
get zeroed out.
But even a little bit of
noise can cause a problem.
Now I'll grant you, we
set this up deliberately
to show a big effect here.
But a 3% error in one data
point is causing a huge problem
when I get further
out on this curve.
And by the way, there
is the r-squared values.
It's 0.7.
It doesn't do a
particularly good job
OK, so how would I fix this?
Well, what if I had
simply done a first degree
fit, same situation.
Let's say fit a line
to this rather than
fitting a quadratic.
Remember, my
question was, what's
the harm of fitting a higher
order model if the coefficients
would be zeroed out?
We've seen they
won't be zeroed out.
But if I were just
to have fit a line
to this, exactly the same
experiment, 0, 0, 1, 1, 2,
2, 3, and 3.1, 20 and 20.
Now you can see it still does
a really good job of fitting.
The r-squared value is 0.9988.
So again, fitting the right
level of model, the noise
doesn't cause nearly
as much of a problem.
And so just to pull that
together, basically it says,
the predictive ability
of the first order model
is much better than
the second order model.
And that's why, in
this case, I would want
to use that first order model.
So take home message.
And then we're going
to amplify this.
If I pick an overly
complex model,
I have the danger of overfitting
to the training data,
overfitting meaning that I'm
not only fitting the underlying
process, I'm fitting the noise.
I get an order 16
model is the best
fit when it's in fact, in order
2 model that was generating it.
That increases the
risk that it's not
going to do well with the
data, not what I'd like.
I want to be able
to predict what's
going to go on well here.
On the other hand.
So that would say, boy,
just stick with the simplest
possible model.
But there's a trade off here.
And we already saw
that when I tried
to fit a line to a data that
was basically quadratic.
I didn't get a good fit.
So I'd want to find the balance.
An insufficiently complex model
won't explain the data well.
An overly complex model will
overfit the training data.
So I'd like to find
the place where
the model is as
simple as possible,
but still explains the data.
And I can't resist the quote
from Einstein that captures it
pretty well, "everything
should be made as simple
as possible, but not simpler."
In the case of
where I started, it
should be fit to a quadratic,
because it's the right fit.
But don't fit more
than that, because it's
getting overly complex
Now how might we go about
finding the right model?
We're not going to dwell on
this but here is a standard way
in which you might do it.
Start with a low order model.
Again, take that data.
Fit a linear model to it.
Look at not only
the r-squared value,
but see how well it
accounts for new data.
Increase the order of the model.
Repeat the process.
And keep doing
that until you find
a point at which a model does
a good job both on the training
data and on predicting new data.
An after it starts
to fall off, that
gives you a point where
you might say there's
a good sized model.
In the case of this data,
whether I would have stopped
at a quadratic or I might
have used a cubic or a quartic
depends on the values.
But I certainly wouldn't
have gone much beyond that.
And this is one way, if
you don't have a theory
to drive you, to think
about, how do I actually fit
the model the way I would like.
Let's go back to
where we started.
We still have one
more big topic to do,
and we still have
a few minutes left.
But let's go back to where
we started Hooke's law.
There was the data from
measuring displacements
of a spring, as I
added different weights
to the bottom of the spring.
And there's the linear fit.
It's not bad.
There's the quadratic fit.
And it's certainly got a
better r-squared value, though.
That could be just
fitting to the noise.
But you actually
can see, I think,
that that green curve
probably does a better
job of fitting the data.
Well, wait a minute.
Even though the quadratic
fit is tighter here,
Hooke says, this is linear.
So what's going on?
Well, this is another
place where you
want to think about your model.
And I'll remind you, in case
you don't remember your physics,
unless we believe
that Hooke was wrong,
this should tell us something.
And in particular, Hooke's
law says, the model
holds until you reach the
elastic limit of the spring.
You stretch a slinky too
far, it never springs back.
You go beyond that
elastic limit.
And that's probably what's
happening right up there.
Through here, it's following
that linear relationship.
Up at this point, I've
essentially broken the spring.
The elastic limit
doesn't hold anymore.
And so really, in this
case, I should probably
fit different models
to different segments.
And there's a much better fit.
Linear through the
first part and another
later line once I hit
that elastic limit.
How might I find this?
Well, you could imagine a little
search process in which you try
and find where's the best
place along here to break
the data into two sets, fit
linear segments to both,
and get really good
fits for both examples.
And I raise it because
that's the kind of thing
you've also seen before.
You could imagine writing
code to do that search
to find that good fit.
OK, that gives
you a sense, then,
of why you want to be
careful about overfitting,
why you want to not just
look at the coefficient
of determination, but see how
well does this predict behavior
on new data sets.
Now suppose I don't have
a theory, like Hooke,
to guide me.
Can I still figure out what's a
good model to fit to the data?
And the answer is, you bet.
We're going to use
cross-validation to guide
the choice of the
model complexity.
And I want to show
you two examples.
If the data set's
small, we can use
what's called leave one
out cross-validation.
I'll give you a definition
of that in a second.
If the data sets
bigger than that,
we can use k-fold
cross-validation.
I'll give you a
definition that a second.
Or just what's called,
repeated random sampling.
But we can use this same
idea of validating new data
to try and figure out whether
the model is a good model
or not.
Leave one out cross-validation.
This is as written
in pseudocode,
but the idea is pretty simple.
I'm given a dataset.
It's not too large.
The idea is to walk
through a number of trials,
number trials equal to
the size of the data set.
And for each one, take the
data set or a copy of it,
and drop out one of the samples.
So leave one out.
Start off by leaving
out the first one,
then leaving out the
second one, and then
leaving out the third one.
For each one of those training
sets, build the model.
For example, by using
linear regression.
And then test that model on that
data point that you left out.
So leave out the first
one, build a model
on all of the other
ones, and then see
how well that model
predicts the first one.
Leave out the second
one, build a model
using all of them
but the second one,
see how well it
predicts the second one.
And just average
the result. Works
when you don't have
a really large data
set, because it
won't take too long.
But it's a nice way of
actually testing validation.
If the data set's
a lot bigger, you
can still use the same idea.
You can use what's
called, k-fold.
Divide the data set up
into k equal sized chunks.
Leave one of them out.
Use the rest to build the model.
And then use that
model to predict
that first chunk you left out.
Leave out the second
chunk, and keep doing it.
Same idea, but now
with groups of things
rather than just leaving
those single data points.
All right, the other way
you can deal with it,
which has a nice
effect to it, is
to use what's called,
repeated random sampling.
OK, start out with
some data set.
And what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to run through
some number of trials.
I'm going to call that, k.
But I'm also going to pick
some number of random samples
from the data set.
Usually, I think,
and as I recall,
it is somewhere between
reserving 20% to 50%
of the samples.
But the idea is again, walk
over all of those k trials.
And in each one, pick
out at random n elements
for the test set.
Use the remainder
is the training set.
Build the model on
the training set.
And then apply that
model to the test set.
So rather than doing
k-fold, where I select k,
in turn, and keep them.
This is just randomly selecting
which ones to pull out.
So I'm going to show
you one last example.
Let's look at that idea of,
I don't have a model here.
I want to use this idea
of cross-validation
to try and figure out what's
the best possible model.
And for this, I'm going to
use a different data set.
The data set here
is I want to model
or the task here is
I want to try model
how the mean daily high
temperature in the US
has varied over about a 55
year period, from '61 to 2015.
Got a set of data.
It's mean-- sorry, the daily
high for every day of the year
through that entire period.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to compute the means for
each year and plot them out.
And then I'm going to try
and fit models to them.
And in particular,
I'm going to take
a set of different
dimensionalities,
linear, quadratic, cubic,
quartic And in each case,
I'm going to run
through a trial where
I train on one half of the
data, test on the other.
There again, is that idea
of seeing how well it
predicts other data.
Record the coefficient
of determination.
And do that and
get out an average,
and report what I get as the
mean for each of those values
across each dimensionality.
OK, here we go.
Set a code that's
pretty easy to see.
Hopefully, you can just
look at it and grok it.
We start off with
a boring class,
which Professor guttag suggests
refers to this lecture.
But it doesn't.
This may be a boring lecture,
but it's not a boring class.
This is a great class.
And boy, those jokes are
really awful, aren't they?
But here we go.
Simple class that
builds temperature data.
This reads in some information,
splits it up, and basically,
records the high for the day and
the year in which I got that.
So for each day, I've got a
high temperature for that day.
I'm going to give you back the
high temperature and the year
in which it was recorded,
because I don't care
whether it was in
January or June.
A little function
that opens up a file.
We've actually given you a file,
if you want to go look at it.
And simply walk through
the file reading it in
and returning a big list
of all those data objects.
OK, then what I
want to do is I want
to get the mean high
temperature for each year.
Given that data, I'm going to
set up a dictionary called,
years.
I'm just going to run through
a loop through all the data
points, where in the
dictionary, under that year.
So there a data point.
I use the method get
year to get out the year.
At that point, I add in the
high temperature corresponding
to that data point.
And I'm using that nice
little try except loop.
I'll do that, unless
I haven't had anything
yet for this year, in
which case this'll fail.
And I'll simply store the
first one in as a list.
So after I've run through
this loop in the dictionary,
under the year, I have a
list of the high temperatures
for each day associated with it.
Excuse me.
And then I can just
compute the average, that
is for each year in the years.
I get that value.
I add them up.
I get the length.
I divide them out.
And I store that in as the
average high temperature
for the year.
Now I can plot it.
Get the data, get
out the information
by computing those yearly
means, run through a little loop
that basically, in the x values,
puts in the year, in the y
values, puts in the
high temperature.
And I can do a plot.
And if I do that, I get that.
I'll let you run this yourself.
Now this is a little bit
deceptive, because of the scale
I've used here.
But nonetheless, it
shows, in the US,
over a 55 year period,
the mean high day--
I'm sorry.
The mean daily high has
gone from about 15.5
degrees Celsius up
to about 17 and 1/2.
So what's changed?
Now the question is,
how could I model this?
Could I actually
get a model that
would give me a sense
of how this is changing?
And that's why I'm going
to use cross-validation.
I'm going to run through a
number of trials, 10 trials.
I'm going to try and fit
four different models,
linear, quadratic,
cubic, quartic.
And for each of
these dimensions,
I'm going to get out a
set of r-squared values.
So I'm just going to initialize
that dictionary. an empty list.
Now here is how I'm
going to do this.
Got a list of x-values.
Those are years.
Got a list of y values.
Those are average
highs, daily highs.
I'm going to create a
list of random samples.
So if you haven't seen this
before, random.sample says,
given this iterator,
which you can think
of as the collection
from 0 up to n minus 1,
it's going to select this many
or half of them, in this case,
of those numbers at random.
So if I give it 0 up to 9,
and I say, pick five of them,
it will, at random, give me
back 5 of those 10 numbers,
with no duplicates.
Ah, that's nice.
Because now notice
what I can do.
I'm going to set up a training--
sorry, an x and y values
for a training set, x
and y values for the test set.
And I'm just going to
run through a loop here,
where if this index
is in that list,
I'll stick it in
the training set.
Otherwise, I'll stick
it in the test set.
And then I just return them.
So this is a really nice
way of, at random, just
splitting the data set into a
test set and a training set.
And then finally, I can run
over the number of trials
I want to deal with.
In each case, get a
different training
and test set, at random.
And then, for each
dimension, do the fit.
There's polyfit on the training
x and training y values
in that dimension.
Gives you back a model.
I could just check to see how
well the training set gets,
but I really want to look
at, given that model,
how well does polyval
predict the test set, right?
The model will say, here's
what I expect is the values.
I'm going to compare
that to the actual values
that I saw from
the training set,
computing that r squared
value and adding it in.
And then the last
of this just says,
I'll run this through
a set of examples.
OK, here's what
happens if I do that.
I'm not going to run it,
although the code will run it.
Let me, again, remind
you what I'm doing.
I got a big set
of data I'm going
to pick out at
random, subsets of it,
build the model on one part,
test it on the other part.
And if I run it, I get a linear
fit, quadratic fit, cubic fit,
and a quartic fit.
And here's the standard
deviation of those samples.
Remember, I've got
multiple trials.
I've got 10 trials,
in this case.
So this gives me the
average over those trials.
And this tells me
how much they vary.
What can I conclude from this?
Well, I would argue that
the linear fit's probably
the winner here.
Goes back to Einstein.
I want the simplest possible
model that accounts for it.
And you can see it's got the
highest r-squared value, which
is already a good sign.
It's got the smallest
deviation across the trials,
which says it's probably
a pretty good fit.
And it's the simplest model.
So linear sounds like
a pretty good fit.
Now, why should we run multiple
data sets to test this?
I ran 10 trials of each
one of these dimensions.
Why bother with it?
Well, notice that
those deviations--
I'll go back to it here--
they're pretty good.
They're about an
order of magnitude
less than the actual mean,
which says they're pretty tight,
but they're still
reasonable size.
And that suggests that,
while there's good agreement,
the deviations are
large enough that you
could see a range of
variation across the trials.
So in fact, if I had
just run one trial,
I could have been screwed.
Sorry, oh-- sorry, pick your
favorite [INAUDIBLE] here.
[? Hose ?] is a
Canadian expression,
in case you haven't seen it.
Here are the r-squared
values for each trial
of the linear fit.
And you can see the mean
comes up pretty well.
But notice, if I'd
only run one trial
and I happened to get
that one, oh, darn.
That's a really low
r-squared value.
And we might have
decided, in this case,
a different conclusion, that the
linear fit was not a good fit.
So this is a way of saying,
even in a random sampling, run
multiple trials,
because it lets you
get statistics on those
trials, as well as statistics
within each trial.
So with any trial, I'm
doing a whole bunch
of different random samples
on measuring those values.
And then, across
those trials, I'm
seeing what the deviation is.
I'm going to hope my
machine comes back,
because what I want to do
is then pull this together.
What have we done?
Something you're going to use.
We've seen how you can
use linear regression
to fit a curve to data,
2D, 3D, 6D, however big
the data set is.
It gives us a mapping from
the independent values
to the dependent values.
And that can then be
used to predict values
associated with the
independent values
that we haven't seen yet.
That leads, naturally,
to both a way
to measure, which is r
squared, but especially
to see that we want to look
at how well does that model
actually predict new data,
because that lets us select
the simplest model we can
that accounts for the data,
but predicts new data
in an effective way.
And that complexity
can either be
based on theory, in the case of
Hooke, or in more likely cases,
by doing cross-validation
to try and figure out
which one is the
simplest model that
still does a good
job of predicting out
of data behavior.
And with that, I'll
see you next time.